[Música]
como lo estábamos adelantando con
nuestro primer invitado del día vamos a
analizar la crisis de energías que se
vive en el mundo y cómo esto afecta la
recuperación económica post pandemia
esto también de cara a la cumbre de la
onu sobre el clima la con 26 que se va a
celebrar en glasgow en escocia y donde
los líderes mundiales tendrán que
acelerar la marcha en busca de estas
energías alternativas y sostenibles y
limpias el gas es el principal
componente que escasea principalmente en
europa por lo que la semana pasada se
reunión a los líderes del bloque para
buscar soluciones a esta crisis por ello
le doy entonces la bienvenida y saludo
en este momento con los buenos días
enrique feas efe ac técnico comercial y
economista investigador principal del
real instituto elcano gracias a enrique
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de frança 24 que ocurre con
energía mundial encantado bueno yo creo
que hay que hay
fundamentalmente es el problema su
problema de gas y se debe a distintos
factores no hay factores meteorológicos
un invierno particularmente duro en el
que los países tuvieron que tirar de sus
reservas para hacer frente a las
necesidades energéticas en el invierno
una escasez de viento que hace que la
electricidad se tenga que producir
fundamentalmente con recursos no
renovables factores económicos como el
importante empuje de la demanda tras la
pandemia y luego factores técnicos como
pueden ser pues los problemas de
suministro que ha habido en noruega y en
rusia que son fundamentales para el
suministro de nuestros países y
podríamos añadir igual incluso una parte
regulatoria que es la estrategia de
reducción de emisiones que lleva a que
ahora los incentivos para invertir en
en combustibles fósiles como el gas pues
se vaya reduciendo y que el precio
lógicamente al disminuir la oferta va
aumentando ahora enrique esta crisis
energética pues se va a incrementar la
podemos seguir viendo a lo largo de los
meses y particularmente como usted bien
lo decía pues en el invierno
especialmente en europa
bueno todo depende de varios factores
depende de cómo sea el invierno es decir
si es un invierno en europa moderado
pues es posible que los precios
anticipan los pedidos de futuros que
igual habría una cierta normalización de
los precios a lo largo de 2022 entonces
no se puede decir que lo que sí que cabe
esperar es todavía precios elevados
hasta por lo menos principios o incluso
mediados de 2022 la cuestión es cómo se
reacciona frente a estas subidas
energéticas y en qué medida eso termina
afectando a digamos a elementos de
segundo orden a subidas de precios de
productos subidas de salarios lo cual
puede desencadenar pues una unas
tensiones inflacionistas que pueden ser
peligrosas por la recuperación ahora
enrique también todo esto no en medio
pues a días a pocos días de iniciar la
cumbre de la cob 26 sobre el cambio
climático ya pues tuvimos en los los
famosos acuerdos de parís que realmente
no se han cumplido como lo esperaban
incluso acaba de decir el primer
ministro británico boris johnson que no
cree que en esta cumple en esta próxima
cumbre con 26 en glasgow se alcancen los
avances necesarios para tratar de
sopesar todo este cambio climático y
buscar otro tipo de energías que está
pasando porque realmente no ponen esto
de agenda primordial porque realmente
esto nos afecta a todos y la economía
que finalmente también es lo que le
preocupa más a los gobiernos
bueno yo creo que lo que está ocurriendo
fundamentalmente es que lo urgente está
desplazando a lo importante todo el
mundo piensa que el tornado está de
acuerdo en la necesidad de reducir
emisiones el problema es cómo se están
enfrentando los distintos países a la
actual crisis energética y en qué medida
deben deben acelerar o piensan algunos
países -china es el mejor ejemplo el
principal emisor de gases de efecto
invernadero que considera que debe
modular un poco sus compromisos de
reducción de emisiones a las necesidades
de recuperación económica y ali a la
gestión de la actual crisis crisis
energética entonces digamos que hay
conflicto entre entre lo que todo el
mundo considera que es importante que es
reducir emisiones cuanto antes por el
bien de la humanidad y en qué medida eso
es compatible o los plazos de
reducciones son compatibles con con
salir de la crisis de una forma adecuada
y sin demasiado coste para los
ciudadanos en términos de precios
energéticos
tocaba un actor muy importante en toda
esta crisis hablamos del 'gigante
asiático' hablamos de china porque está
también teniendo una crisis escasez de
carbón no también en las fábricas
obviamente china es el principal pues
motor produce la mayoría de materias
primas chips para muchísimas industrias
sobre todo la tecnológica como eso
también está afectando el comercio
mundial y como china no hace nada o si
ya empezó a hacer algo para poder paliar
esta crisis
hombre qué pena que interrumpa porque
además también le merma sus ingresos el
producto interno bruto que se reduce
altamente y también se suman las otras
pequeñas crisis que puedan tener como la
crisis financiera de su principal banco
y el digamos que la crisis energética se
enmarca dentro de una crisis general de
oferta a nivel mundial inducida por la
pandemia por la ruptura de las cadenas
de valor en algunos casos porque algunas
fábricas se han paralizado en otros
casos porque se han paralizado la
extracción de determinados minerales que
eran
imprescindibles para la fabricación de
determinados productos o en unos casos
simplemente porque el transporte pues
sufre también así de restricciones en
términos de buques de contenedores
estamos viviendo una crisis de oferta
que está que está generando unas
tensiones importantes sobre los precios
de determinados productos determinadas
materias primas y eso afecta ha afectado
particularmente hacia donde hemos visto
pues la enorme dependencia que tenemos
pues de microprocesadores producidos en
taiwán o de otra serie de productos
china que es actualmente la fábrica del
mundo pues está sufriendo
más más que nada cuando práctica además
una política muy restrictiva en términos
de comida es decir en prácticas
restricciones a la movilidad y al
funcionamiento de la economía en seguida
cada vez que hay un brote y eso hace que
la recuperación de digamos de los
niveles productivos sea muy inferior a
la demanda que se está recuperando ya un
nivel muy elevado
estos estrangulamientos de la oferta
pues por todos los ámbitos en el
energético y además en los precios de
las materias primas y determinados
productos intermedios o bienes de equipo
pues pueden generar tensiones de precios
que lleven a la necesidad de
moderar la demanda el problema es que
una subida de tipos de interés tendría
otros problemas económicos generaría
otra serie de tensiones económicas
financieras en el mundo que tampoco son
muy recomendables todo el mundo espera
que los precios se moderen a lo largo
del tiempo y que podamos resistir sin
necesidad de subir tipos de interés pero
todo lo contrario enrique porque parece
que los precios van en aumento no
incluso la empresa unilever anunció un
incremento en casi la mayoría de sus
productos y por supuesto esto hace que
todo el comercio mundial también como
incrementar los precios
hacia donde hacia dónde vamos con esto
exactamente se están aumentando los
precios pero no hay que confundir la
inflación
digamos o la subida de precios temporal
con un crecimiento permanente del nivel
general de precios que es lo que es la
inflación los precios están subiendo por
diversos motivos y por estrangulamiento
de la oferta por problemas de la energía
los pesos están subiendo
considerablemente la cuestión en qué
medida todos estos precios se
trasladarán después a crecimientos de
salarios ya su vez al crecimiento de
nuevos precios y eso llevará una espiral
de precios y salarios que se traduzcan
en fuertes tensiones inflacionistas que
sea necesario acometer el problema es
que tampoco podemos precipitarnos y
pensar que simplemente por subir tipos
de interés el problema se va a
solucionar porque ya aprendimos en los
años 80 que cuando los problemas de
inmigración vienen por el lado de la
oferta a subir tipos de interés lo que
hace es todavía empeorar más la
situación económica general y generar
tensiones financieras y sostenibles en
determinadas regiones pues enrique
complicado entonces el panorama
económico en cuanto también a la energía
que estamos viviendo muchísimas gracias
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
directo américa aquí en france 24